I smoked $30,000 worth of cigars
consequently had nicotine poisoning and
Christmas break when others went off to
buy presents and decorate their
Christmas trees I went and had a
colonoscopy hello my name is Gary Oldman
and welcome to another episode of lads
on film it was a great experience
working with Chris Nolan really over the
three movies over seven years so that in
itself getting the chance to actually
develop a character and revisit a
character was was it was an
extraordinary thing I managed to work
with Michael Caine it you know it's an
interesting thing as an actor you can
worship and hero-worship people and you
sometimes actually get a chance to work
with those people that you hero-worship
and I'd been a fan of Michael Caine for
years so it was wonderful to get to work
with Michael and watch Michael work up
close he can do it in one take on the
money and he's an absolute Pro the
master had it and it was real good
acting lesson I'm working with him the
one that comes to mind is I did Air
Force One with Harrison Ford and we were
on a set which was obviously the
aircraft of Air Force One there were
signs everywhere there was no drinking
no smoking and no eating on the set and
there was one day when I looked around
and Harrison was standing in the doorway
beneath the sign that said no smoking no
drinking and no eating and he was
drinking a coffee eating a burrito while
smoking a cigar and he was doing all
three
I smoked $30,000 worth of cigars I got
through about 12 a day and had
consequently had nicotine poisoning and
Christmas break when others went off to
buy presents and decorate their
Christmas trees I went and had a
colonoscopy well I am coming up to a
milestone I'm nearly 60 I will be 60 in
March and there was no no way that I
could gain 70 pounds to play Churchill
so makeup was really the only way to go
but there were pies and bacon sandwiches
and sausage rolls going back to that
thing of getting to work with your
heroes I managed to work with John Hurt
and that was one of the big highlights
of my career not only had I admired him
for years as a wonderful actor but then
getting to work with him and getting to
know him he was an absolute darling of a
man he was such a beautiful human being
and he was cast in darkest hour and I
was so thrilled to be able to work with
him again
and as we know he had cancer on the very
first day of the darkest hour the the
read-through that morning getting out of
bed he fell had broken his leg and
really it was sawed downhill from there
and sadly he passed but yeah my regret
is I didn't get to work with John again